FOR POLICE OFFICERS WHO BREAK
THE RULES.
DEALING WITH ACCOUNTABILITY IN
TERMS OF LEGAL ACCOUNTABILITY SO
ALL THOSE THINGS NEED TO HAPPEN.
>> IT IS A FALSE CHOICE THAT YOU
DON’T HAVE TO HURT THE POLICE
WHEN YOU DEFUND THEM.
>> THEY ARE FULL OF DUMB IDEAS,
WE GET THAT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CANCELED THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE, THEY DUMPED A
BUNCH OF ENERGY JOBS HERE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY MAKING PUTIN
RICHER, ALSO WANT TO TEACH
DISCRIMINATION BY TEACHING KIDS
TO DISCRIMINATE.
HAVING SAID THAT.
TRIOSING WITH SOME IDEAS WAS THE
SINGLE DUMBEST IDEA THEY EVER
HAD, THEY ARE TRYING TO BLAME
REPUBLICANS FOR IT.
YOU HAVE TO BE A DUNCE WITH A
DUNCE CAP SITTING IN THE QUARTER
TO BELIEVE THIS STUFF.
THEY MADE A MISTAKE BECAUSE
GOING FORWARD, THEY PUT
THEMSELVES IN A BOX, PUSHING A
BILL RIGHT NOW, AFFIRMATIVE FAIR
HOUSING, RIPPED MONEY AWAY FROM
LOCALITIES IF YOU DON’T PUT
SECTION 8 IN THE SUBURB THAT
WOULD DEFUND THE POLICE, PUSHING
THAT HYPE NOW WHILE CLAIMING
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING IT AND I
CONFRONTED MY GUESTS ON
UNFILTERED, THEY ARE
REPUBLICANS, THIS WILL BE A
DISASTER FOR THEM IN THE
MIDTERMS BECAUSE PUBLIC SAFETY
IS THE ISSUE THAT TAKES YOU AT
THE KITCHEN TABLE.
YOU CAN ARGUE ABOUT TAX RATES
FOR YOUR CAR GETS BROKEN INTO
THAT ISSUE BECOMES PERSONAL,
THEY KNOW THEY ARE IN TROUBLE.
>> NUMBERS BACK YOU UP.
THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF DEPLOYING
MORE POLICE OFFICERS, 77% OF
PEOPLE SUPPORT INCREASING POLICE
DEPARTMENT BUDGETS, THE 2020
ELECTION WAS SO MUCH ABOUT
PERSONALITY, ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
AND WHAT THAT COVERS UP IS THE
IDEA NOT JUST DEFUND THE POLICE
BUT MANY MORE IDEAS ARE
INCREDIBLY UNPOPULAR, THAT THE
LEFT HAS BEEN CHAMPIONING, WHAT
IS COMING AHEAD.
WE WORRY ABOUT OUR CULTURE AND
WE SHOULD, IT MAY BE THERE IS A
RAY OF HOPE THAT THE PUBLIC DOES
NOT WANT THESE IDEAS THAT GOT A
SIGNIFICANT HEARING IN THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS.
>> LIBERAL VERSUS CONSERVATIVE
ISSUES, THEY CAN’T GET LOST,
THEY GO TO WORK OR THE KIDS
SOCCER GAMES IF TAX RATES GO UP
A FEW POINTS, THEY CATCH THEIR
ACCOUNT AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
A CHECK THEY BARELY SEE IS
DIRECT DEPOSITED BUT THAT’S NOT
THE CASE WITH THIS ISSUE.
WHEN IT COMES TO CRIME IT
HAPPENS IN FRONT OF YOU.
THAT IS WHY CORONAVIRUS IS A BIG
ISSUE.
EVERYBODY KNEW SOMEONE WHO HAD
IT.
I LIVED THROUGH IT IN NEW YORK
CITY WHEN RUDY GIULIANI IN A
MAJOR UPSET WON THE MAYORSHIP
TWICE BECAUSE CRIME IS HITTING
PEOPLE IN THEIR OWN HOMES, THEY
CAN’T RUN FROM IT.
>> IN NEW YORK, THE CITY IS SO
DIFFERENT OVER THE LAST 6 OR 7
YEARS THE WHOLE PLACE SMELLS
LIKE URINE AND POT AND THERE’S
CRIME EVERYWHERE.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
>> DON’T BE SORRY.
>> I HATE SAYING IT.
>> IT IS THE GREATEST CITY ON
EARTH.
THEY SHOULD TREAT IT AS SUCH.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD, A
LOT OF PEOPLE GETTING PAID NOT
TO GO TO WORK, BUSINESSES ARE
HURT.
PEOPLE CAN’T FIND ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO WORK AT ALL THESE JOB
OPENINGS.
DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW
STUPID THE POLICY IS THAT WHAT
IS DOING FOR THE CULTURE, THE
WORK ETHIC IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> THAT MATTERS.
I OPENED MY SHOW LAST WEEK
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
WE LAUGH A LOT ON THIS WHEN WE
HAVE EMOTIONAL ISSUES BUT THIS
IS SERIOUS, NOT JUST THAT PAYING
PEOPLE NOT TO WORK IS NOT
COMPASSIONATE, IT IS OUTRIGHT
EVIL.
THE DIFFERENCE, SOMEONE FALLING
ON THE SIDEWALK AND DON’T HELP
THEM UP, YOU DIDN’T DO ANYTHING.
MALFEASANCE IS WHEN YOU PUNCH
THEM IN THE FACE AS THEY TRIED
TO GET UP.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
DEPRAVITY THERE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN REGARDS
TO THIS?
WHEN YOU ROB PEOPLE OF THE
DIGNITY OF
DIGNITY OF A JOB BY
INCENTIVIZING THEM, SOME PEOPLE
MAXIMIZE.
I CAN MAKE WAR AT HOME, YOU ROB
THEM OF EVERYTHING, THE
EXPERIENCE OF SOCIALIZING WITH
OTHER HUMAN BEINGS AS MILTON
FRIEDMAN SAID, THE ABILITY TO
MANIPULATE YOUR ENVIRONMENT AND
LEARN THE VALUE OF GOOD WORK TO
PRODUCE SOMETHING OF VALUE WHICH
I CLEANED MODELING AND IN A
CEMETERY, LAUGH ALL YOU WANT,
THE CLEANEST TOILET BOWL YOU
EVER SAW, I UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT
IS WHAT I WAS PAID TO DO AND
WHEN YOU ROB PEOPLE OF THAT
YOU’VE STOLEN EVERY PART OF
BEING HUMAN, THE ABILITY TO LIVE
ON THIS PLANET AND SAY IT IS
BETTER BECAUSE I WAS HERE.
IT IS EVIL.
NOT JUST NOT COMPASSIONATE AND
WRONG.
>> CANNOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
>> THIS IS WHY YOU HAVE A SHOW
AND PEOPLE LOVE IT.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE ON THE PROGRAM?
>> YOU HAD JESSE ON BEFORE,
PERFORMANCE-ENHANCING PILLS, I
CAUGHT IT, I WATCH YOUR SHOW AND
HE’S ON TONIGHT AND I HAVE A
VIDEO THAT IS A HUGE SURPRISE.
NO IDEA IT IS COMING TALKING
ABOUT PERSISTENCE, A NAVY SEAL,
IMMIGRANTS INSISTS COUNTRY.
THE GUY IS GOING TO BLOW YOUR
MIND.